hello everyone scp-049 here today I am
playing a new game called bio ink
Redemption this is something new I'm
trying out very much still a medical
based game so I think everybody will
like it
you can choose life or death that is you
can heal or you could not heal all of
these concepts is very alien to me but
let's just start with life shall we it's
kind of confusing that I cannot start
anything else but med school but if I
have to I have no other choice
internship no other choice name your
patient hmm I'm not very creative so
living this will be kind difficult well
I don't want to go with John Smith what
about I can't use the Cure because I
can't cure the cure that's a little bit
silly let's see what about further what
about patient zero that sounds good to
me
patient zero I have no idea what I'm
looking at here
I haven't played the game solder
everything anything unlocked so I have
no Bruce's let's just stop so what do we
have here nervous system loss you know
so they appeared in the digestive areas
huh
bio points let's see what we're looking
at so this is a map flu symptoms not
tested h1n1 not tested hmm okay well I
assume I will need to gather bio points
to later spend on investigating on this
poor fellow seems to be suffering from
circulatory seems to be suffering a
little bit
[Music]
so the flu seems to be recommended as
some kind of ailment he may be suffering
from although apologies why I figure out
what it is I'm supposed to do here this
seems to be very different
Oh upgrade source upgrade resources
right I may very well do that I have a
later day more bio points
right so respiratory failure not likely
flu still is likely
[Music]
so this seems to be the right so if I
begin testing this he should have one of
the two of these suggested ailment if
I'm correct I'm not quite sure what I'm
going to do when I realize he has these
four more possibility you can only test
for a set number at a time
[Music]
test results negative okay well that was
a waste of bio points I suppose they're
tests of the mission at the end of the
day on them
[Music]
could scan for the vase I suppose wiring
more bio points here respiratory failure
negative hmm right I can't do that hmm
using my own something happened there I
don't know what that was psychiatric
assisted psychiatric assessment negative
don't run that don't have enough my end
points is it low so let's see if we can
do it now that I do have enough by our
point right so pneumothorax I'm not sure
if that's how you actually say that okay
so scanning for chest scanning using a
chest x-ray which was inconclusive
[Music]
okay muscular dystrophy hmm
his nervous system seems to be suffering
the most him though the blue gives you
three it's good to know try not to miss
those I don't know should I just let
this man die isn't really worth it at
the end of the day I suppose if this was
real life I suppose the answer would be
yes but this is after all computer-based
entertainment so we should spur on in an
effort to maybe save this person's life
having muscle
[Music]
so there's an MRI and a psychiatric
assessment I hope one of them yield some
results psychiatric assessment that was
negative this is unfortunate I want to
try and scan for as much as possible at
once look at this problem but you're
just willing to try anything I don't
know if I'm right in saying this but
would I be right in saying that oh there
we go
test results positive my potential blood
clots stroke and Parkinson's disease
okay well I suppose that's that's a plus
in how how do I treat it upgrade
resources harvest power is always good
I assume the more bio points you have
the more you new symptom paralysis
biopsy results negative this is very
very annoying very annoying I can treat
it now right
[Music]
not enough bio points let's harvest more
shall we and harvest boost is really
coming in quite handy right about now
okay I wonder I suppose treating more
than one thing at a time might be
beneficial so that's being treated now
good my harvested newly acquired by a
point so I can treat up to three things
at once providing I have the points good
harvesting harvesting so much harvesting
so this is being cured that has been
cured right so let's try name form or
symptom that there we go
electroencephalogram positive chronic
stress well I suppose I would be too if
that was me
antidepressants stress stress management
therapy I apologize for my elocution
today I'm not quite with it seems more
harvesting here two treatments completed
42% of the way to recovery okay
ameri-ghen morale-boosting urological
exam good positive again I like it
physiotherapy and what a bargain at 8 by
0.4 a bargain and likewise here only
low-cost
well that's paid for at least one of
them emergency room critical condition
here's been submitted to the emergency
room no pressure here not not a bit of
pressure I'm fine I'm absolutely fine
describe this
sure was a breath let's test for this
just x-rays last time didn't yield
anything but and it was the same again
fine right nervous system with
circulatory system are very very low
about as well so let us Mel operator
right okay
sixteen percent
[Music]
no don't have enough bio points this is
looking quite quite bad for this job
right swelling and bruising
mmm nothing here
music is very dramatic
chronic bronchitis
could it be bone x-rays let's give this
a try circulatory system seems to be
very low learn x-rays negative well
there you go
intensive care
this could buy me a little time
hopefully it does okay well let's boost
it a little bit now nervous system and
the muscular system are still in
jeopardy there is a chance I might lose
this judging by how I've played so far
will be that surprised but I meant to
keep it up as much as I can I am earning
by your points cease spiral just we're
monitoring chest x-rays it's good for
that yes as much as I can do stethoscope
negative oh damn it
chest x-rays negative of the time I was
under the impression that new ailments
would appear that you tests I'll run
this
this music really is really really is
stressing out 0:49 getting stressed haha
funny I bet you're all loving this of
you well it doesn't have a spa good
negative negative negative
okay why not your analysis why not
shortness of breath seems to be a things
let's try and run as many respiratory
tests as possible i was- spirometer
whatever that is respiratory monitoring
negative your analysis please come on no
no great good good good
can we rather any more tests hmm do me a
favor please please come up positive for
something that I can drink this muscular
system is absolutely banjaxed utter ban
Jackson I'm just making up words now oh
good lord
well I cholesterol okay well that's and
devein the deep vein thrombosis if I
could say the words I could read them in
time
okay look I'm not gonna read it
just treat as much as possible come on
I think his muscles are pretty much
dissipated by now system failure
well you can still move without muscles
I think no you can't not really cuz your
heart's a muscle isn't it I'll make them
for getting my medical training right
now this case stressing me out to such
an extent all right
boost it up the muscular system again
but issue you can't live without them in
fact I think the point of this game is
everything on the left you can't live
without
right mirror regeneration that's
something to keep in the back pocket
and it's really indictment I never knew
a Mediterranean died out bar could be
useful for me in the future right ska
like that let's see it's about another
test
though he's eating good it's good for
that Mediterranean diet pulmonary
embolism positive we can't prescribe
anything losing our bone points all
right let's not see if we can get more
of those shall we okay
right 76% recovery almost there he has
been sick for almost a full year 96
almost there almost there
dust run all the tests 4% and he lives
positive and Jana
well for God's sake sorry you died I
didn't have enough bio points yes try
explaining that to the family and
arrhythmia everything to do with this
heart pretty much everything I really
need to learn to test more in the future
subscribe that only for bio points left
that is a relief I'm not going to lie I
really didn't think I was going to win
that well I hope you enjoyed that
everyone because that is the most tense
of a let's play I have ever played Wow
well again thank you very much for
watching and I hope you join me again
next time for another episode of bio-ink
Redemption now I'm going to go and have
a heart attack and goodbye thank you
[Music]